[Music]
hey you guys it's sunday yeah kind of a
lazy sunday yeah i was down to rocket
bar though well i was riding around well
and i was working so it wasn't really
lazy
you worked the whole time yeah not the
whole time what are you doing
made i made a video made an edited video
i made like a couple of other videos and
yeah i was working on about the shirts
i haven't gotten around to shirts yet no
i just i keep forgetting because i have
a million other things
it's like you know i don't really they
take a really long time to do yeah so i
mean to design them so it's kind of like
all right
yeah dj dj's in there said he saw a
blood vessel he said that movie was
highly recommended he liked it he
finally got around to seeing it
yeah that is a very good movie i told
you man
estrada is a [ __ ] better monster than
a vampire
i mean it could have sex with a dead
body and give birth to a [ __ ] child
that's some weird [ __ ]
you can have two stragglers [ __ ]
having sex with each other and give
birth to a living stronghold
or a [ __ ] living struggle they can
have sex with it with an undead
and [ __ ] give birth to a [ __ ]
child it's [ __ ] weird man
so i had families that's some weird [ __ ]
i was telling him just now that there
was uh i was flipping through 2b earlier
looking for
uh movies to review and there's a movie
on there called strigoi yeah but i said
from the artwork it looks like it's
probably terrible but i'm not really
sure it might be one of those kind of
like uh what do you call them asylum
like ripoff yeah i'm not really now
and then like then they [ __ ] then it
tops itself
not only does it have natural abilities
that you're born with as a stronghold
it's also understands magic it can cast
a spell
that's some [ __ ] bizarre [ __ ] there
well yeah i mean he's got like kind of
the list of both worlds
[Laughter]
gonna yeah up this rc cola
that's right yeah we got a fridge full
of
the official soda of burt reynolds
that's right there's some southern [ __ ]
here man from georgia they're saying oh
that's from iowa now georgia
the original rc code was from georgia
okay it doesn't really matter if you
like it it doesn't matter where it comes
from
yeah
even got the 70s old school said i
remember when it looked like that
i kind of feel like a lot of brands are
kind of going back to their sort of
retro because i think burger king did
that in a couple other ones not they're
not exactly the same but they do like
they're trying to like make their logo
look more like retro yeah because the
90s can sucked
it was just blue with the [ __ ] with a
red r and a c looked like it was
airbrushed on there it looked it looks
like [ __ ] yeah well i wasn't a big fan
of like 90s graphic design generally
it looked like something from taco bell
yeah like a special at taco bell
talk about how terrible [ __ ] tv says
damn they still make rc yeah apparently
oh yeah i didn't know they did either
but rc
there's the proof right there he just
bought him at the dollar general the
redcoats bought it
it's owned by schweppes now it is
british
yes
it's shrubs is british isn't it yeah i
guess it is
all right so uh we're talking about a
movie
now i think
that i brought up this movie here the
first power
back when we reviewed the believers
because for whatever well i'm not going
to say for whatever reason because
there's probably a reason but i kind of
conflate i don't confuse them but i kind
of like the believers and the first
power even though they came out three
years apart like the believers actually
came out three years before this did but
i always kind of like put them together
i think i guess because it's sort of
thematically similar in the sense that
it's like a satanic not necessarily
satanic but it's like cult murder type
situation um and it's kind of like a
police procedural thing with
supernatural elements so
i guess that's why like i put those two
things together
it's a good movie but i think back when
we were talking about the believers i
said oh i should re-watch uh the first
power like one of these days because i
haven't seen it in a long time pretty
sure i saw it in the theater when it
first came out in 1990
but so when i was like scrolling through
2b last night looking for something to
watch to review i'm like oh well there
it is the first power and i was like
we're going to watch that [ __ ] and uh
and we'll see
how how it is because i haven't seen it
for such a long time movie takes you
back
yeah it's kind of retro you know what i
mean like and you forgot what movies in
the early 90s were like
it's still kind of 80s yeah gotta say i
mean because 1990 was still pretty 80s
like very sophisticated 80s
you know visually very sophisticated 80s
um i liked it it had a good score the
acting was pretty good there was some
[ __ ] that was not believable like
lou diamond phillips and i don't know
how they eat that [ __ ] training
me into saying his middle name all the
time lou diamond phillips he's just like
yeah you got to say all three
and you just can't say little phillips
you gotta say no you gotta say diamond
in that [ __ ]
i don't know how that happened but he's
not credible as a [ __ ]
as a as a police detective he's far too
young and good looking well i think that
and i'm not even sure i'm not even sure
how old he was when he made this film
but it's like even if he was old enough
to technically be a detective he's kind
of like baby face yeah you know what i
mean and he's boss and other cops around
that are a lot older than him you know
in reality this this guy would have been
in his 50s and he'd have been skinny fat
you know you wouldn't be hot ass lou
diamond phillips
that [ __ ] 25 black duster yeah
that's not how it really goes but it's
it's a movie do you know it's just a
movie you're watching it and you're
going yeah i've been drinking it yeah
yeah yeah you're watching it you guys
know that that's right i forgot you guys
know that because i'm sitting there
going no you haven't i was like oh yeah
you've been in the bar all day
yeah look i got all kinds of free drinks
did you read yeah i got all kinds of
what did you have to do for that nothing
just [ __ ] talking did you just hold
hands or something no i didn't no i wish
they'd have been owing me all kinds of
money if i was pool dancing anyway you
like thrust your crotch out and get like
put some dollar bills in there
[ __ ] with the damn jukebox car but uh
like a cheap hoe yeah but uh no
i'm watching this [ __ ] you know what i
mean it's taking me back to the 90s
i'll tell you what though it's a good
movie it doesn't really have any what's
what's refreshing about the movie is
that there's absolutely no messaging at
all
there's no social commentary there's no
political [ __ ] it's just a story
pure entertainment
um so the movie actually runs pretty
smoothly
uh now towards the last
one third of the movie there
it started to bog down a little bit in
edit
um it
it's it kind of slowed down but then it
picked back up it's just
the edit is not
totally modern it's not real
correct but it's still a good movie it's
good movie
it was actually better than i remember i
sort of kind of remembered what it was
about
um it's uh yeah it's essentially like a
serial killer like detective serial
killer story yeah but with supernatural
elements wanna say it's kind of similar
a little bit to
wes craven's movie shocker which i think
came out a year before this
um not exactly the same but shocker was
also about a serial killer that gets
electrocuted and then comes back to life
or possesses people through electricity
or something like that it's been a long
time since i've seen it uh another movie
that this is like that came out much
later
was the denzel washington movie fallen
which essentially had a killer that
could jump from body to body so he could
like uh you know their different
identities and stuff and that came out
in 1998 and i think i saw that in the
theater as well um but it's kind of
similar to this it's not exactly the
same but the it's kind of like a similar
setup there's a lot of late
80s early 90s movies that feel like this
though
a lot of the movies of the early 90s
felt like this
yeah and i mean this did pretty well
like at the box office i feel like it
didn't really get that great of reviews
at the time and really you don't hear
i'm sure it has like a small cult
following but you don't really hear a
lot of people talking about it um
nowadays
i just kind of feel like it was one of
those ones that fell through the cracks
a little bit but for whatever reason
just like the believers
for some reason i just like remembered
something about it and so i wanted to
like re-watch it i think i saw this
[ __ ] in the theater i think i did as
well i did yeah
i remember i remember everybody liking
it like oh yeah yeah first power that's
good oh yeah it was kind of like what
was the other one where the
serpent the rainbow was like kind of
like that yeah and um
what was the other one
that was from the early 90s it was kind
of like this um
there were just a lot of movies that
were like this there i kind of feel like
i'm i'm struggling to like remember some
other ones but i know there were i feel
like there was kind of like a little
mini trend yeah it kind of felt like
this of sort of serial killer or police
procedural type movies crossbred with
like supernatural [ __ ] yeah yeah and
maybe that started in the late 80s but i
do kind of feel like there was
uh there was like a little bit kind of
like what was the one seven
well the seven deadly sins
yeah although that was just a serial
killer yeah but it was kind of like that
same police procedural
and there's killers in it
silence of the lambs of course which
came out in 1991 even that's not
supernatural either but no and that
movie was a lot better than this one
well yeah obviously i mean that movie is
better than most movies yeah but it's
just
just an enjoyable movie
you know
yeah
hugo says la bamba was okay but i liked
lou diamond phillips since young guns
yeah a lot of young guns was actually
really good
i haven't seen a long time diamond but
what he said diamond yeah that
[ __ ] makes you say his middle
name every time i go okay
what do you want me to do
that's what it is
how he how he got that done
where he makes a [ __ ] say his
middle name every time
well you can do that too if you wanted
to damn you could make your middle name
i don't know just make my [ __ ] knocker
and you can see everybody call you tom
cocknock or ross yeah and i don't
believe that diamond is his real middle
name he made that up
well you know people can make up i'm
gonna call my middle name like yeah
okay
i'm gonna get in trouble
yeah probably gonna get trouble i can
say anything
that's probably best i'm not gonna say
anything um yeah end of days gramphers
brings that up yeah that was another one
that was like a cop movie that was
although that one was kind of terrible
yeah
even though
was in it and i love gabriel byrne and
the days wasn't isn't that the one that
had uh arnold in it yeah that's what i
just said yeah that movie sucked yeah it
was terrible honestly i saw that one in
the theater too and like i wanted to
like walk out
i just i don't know i just really did it
i have it on blu-ray yeah and well
because
yeah you brought it on blu-ray and i
said well i'll watch it again i'll give
it another chance because i just
remember seeing at the theater being
like what the [ __ ] was that all about
yeah i wanted to have all the arnold's
old stuff and i bought that [ __ ] on
blu-ray and watched it and i was just
like the only thing that was good about
it was the uh was the score
yeah it had good music
but i'm just going man this mother this
is this thing is a piece of [ __ ] it's
just like terrible it really is terrible
terrible um but yeah so this well this
movie is a lot better than that yeah uh
straw dog 78 says i always confuse this
with the seventh sign that was one that
was one to me more right honestly i
think somebody sent us that yeah we got
on dvds yeah did we ever review it i
kind of thought we did i think we did
yeah but i can't remember if we did if
we didn't i'm sorry yeah it will get
around to it we'll get right it is in
that realm these movies so they're yeah
i kind of feel like yeah it was like
like a little bit of a mini trend yeah
there the white worm was almost like
these two even though it was different
yeah
it was tour british that [ __ ] was
british that would no that was ken
russell that was like crazy as [ __ ] oh
and that was and that was like folk
horror that didn't have anything it was
they're the white that wasn't serial
killer no but i was just saying the way
the movies it was that same era i guess
yeah but layer the white worm also kind
of reminded me in a way of [ __ ] like
a better version of raw head rex
yeah yeah
zack says oh yeah two of my favorite
people streaming about a movie i've
never heard of lol today has been so
important
like i said i kind of feel like it's
weird
it's free man go watch it it's it's it's
it's on 2b um
well yeah and like i said i saw it a
long time ago and honestly i hadn't seen
a long time there's not a [ __ ] ton well
i don't know there was a handful of
other horror channels that covered this
and actually there was one guy on there
who i uh watch off and on and he did
like a 36 minute thing about it and how
like he was really really into it yeah
so i thought that was kind of nice
what's funny is that this is like he
said i've never even heard of this movie
you know when this movie came out it was
like a big deal i remember this being in
fangoria it might have even been on the
cover
or there was for sure like a big article
about it when it was coming out i
remember all my [ __ ] buddies like oh
man we got to see that oh that's going
to be badass
well yeah you know and [ __ ] it was
kind of a the flavor of the day you were
like oh yeah yeah it was that was a good
movie and then quickly forgotten
replaced by another one
might have something to do with youth
you know you're young so it's a bigger
impression on you probably didn't make
any impression on anybody else but we
liked it
and i still and it obviously made some
kind of impression because i remembered
the title like after all these years
and uh you know and i actually went and
watched it when i saw it come up so okay
so what the story about this is lou
diamond phillips is playing a cop
and
uh so there's a serial killer who's
called the pentagram killer he's played
by jeff kober who also
he always plays
bad guys i guess if you have a face that
looks like that
you pretty much just always have to play
bad guys and psychos because he just has
that kind of face i guess
uh so yeah so this killer is going
around uh you know killing people
obviously and then carving pentagrams
into their bodies
and quite near the beginning of the film
there's kind of this thing where
uh lou diamond phillips character who's
what's his name logan well that's his
last name his first name is russell but
they usually call him logan
and he has a thing where he has this
woman who you don't know who who it is
until later but she keeps calling him
and she seems to know where the panic
the i almost called him the pentagon
killer the pentagram killer where the
pentagram killer is going to strike next
so he's kind of like thinking is this
this serial killer's girlfriend like
what's going on with this how does she
know all this information so at the
beginning they kind of have this big
confrontation one of the undercover cops
uh gets almost murdered and there's this
big thing and they do actually end up
catching the serial killer quite near
the beginning of the movie now one of
the things that the anonymous woman that
kept calling him said if you catch him
don't give him the death penalty
five minutes later after they catch him
of course he gets the death penalty and
lou downfall is like woo go us you know
we're gonna like give him the [ __ ]
death penalty obviously like several
months have gone by because he gets
stabbed and it's healed and all this
other stuff
so what ends up happening is that they
give they put him in the gas chamber
and uh he doesn't die
so
what it's kind of like a biblical thing
essentially is so the killer
is
trying to get or did get what is called
the first power which is
resurrection so he can resurrect himself
and also he has i think this is how this
goes he also has the second power which
is possession
so he can actually like hop from person
to person
uh and when he hops in the body so he
can continue like the killing
after he's presumably already dead so
he's got like magic powers and [ __ ] so
like i said for a long time lou diamond
phillips obviously as most normal people
would doesn't believe that the serial
killer is still alive and is actually
able to like possess people and then he
meets up with the anonymous woman who
turns out to be a psychic who must make
a lot of money psychic because she's got
like a really really big awesome house
with like a rich
she's one of those bridges
she wants to have some sylvia brown
level [ __ ] yeah or something like this
is the funny thing all right i'm
watching this movie
and i really i remember being able to
follow this movie as a kid and like
being being able to like buy into it and
to immerse myself into and keeping track
of who's possessed and all this [ __ ]
watching it as an adult i wasn't buying
it at all you're like yeah right
well i mean it's the premise is kind of
outlandish but i mean of the time yeah
it was a movie of the time and it's just
one of those well you know the premise
of a lot of movies any horror movie or
fantasy movie or anything like that
outlandish yeah
so you just gotta like [ __ ] roll with
it man yeah and you know you have to
just uh you know you just have to accept
the fact that this serial killer by
killing a whole bunch of people to and
sacrificing them to satan essentially is
what he's doing um he's able to get all
these magical powers
and now i will say one thing yeah so it
does get crazier and crazier like toward
the end there's like there's a log i got
it i gotta see it's not a long flume
there's like a flying bag lady it's a
lot of things
but what
the best part of the [ __ ] movie that
as soon as i saw it i it [ __ ] brought
me back i remembered it is when one of
the possessed guys or the demon dudes
pulls a [ __ ] ceiling fan off of the
ceiling all right
breaks it free of the [ __ ] electrical
wires and everything and holds it out in
front of him and the fan blade starts
spinning fast as a [ __ ] and he's
using it as a weapon and i just started
to [ __ ] laugh sounds like wait how
does that work
[Laughter]
i remember seeing that as a kid and it
blow my [ __ ] mind i thought we'd
establish that but seeing it as an adult
was was different but it was okay i was
like all right i thought that was pretty
great yeah that was pretty great to be
honest and as much as i made a joke
about the flying bag lady yeah i
actually really did like that scene yeah
because he possesses this homeless woman
that's like laying outside of his arm
out inside of the psychics or outside of
his apartment building and the bag
ladies like flies up like toward the
window and then she busts through the
window and she's like jumping on and
stuff there is a [ __ ] some ex
excellent [ __ ] stunts i was gonna say
some of the stunt work in this is
incredible dude jumps off a building and
you can see from the shots that is a
real man [ __ ] fallen and then they
just as he hits the ground they [ __ ]
cut away and the dude just lands on the
ground and walks and runs off
totally on cause like i said he's
supernatural he jumps off like a 10
story building and then he just lands
like
and it was great it was great it was
great editing so you buy it you're like
oh wow [ __ ] i know i saw that sound i
was like holy [ __ ] you look good yeah
well i will say one thing though now i
don't know
how easy it is to get this on blu-ray
one of the other we watched it on to be
and i didn't uh have this issue but i
was watching another review of this and
somebody had the
blu-ray edition
and they said the only problem is that
the blu-ray transfer is really like the
hd transfer is so good that all of those
stunts you can see the wire oh there's
wire like yeah you can see the wire like
on the guy
and um i couldn't see it like on the 2b
version
but
apparently on the blu-ray because of and
i've that's happened a lot i've heard
about that happening a lot with um older
movies where you know when they make the
transfer to high definition you can see
a lot of stuff in there that you
couldn't see like when you played in the
theme like the black hole
yeah that kind of stuff so apparently um
you can see all the wire work like on
all the stunts for this which is kind of
a shame because i was like really amazed
not i mean that where he jumps off the
10-story building and like just lands on
his feet and runs off that's a great
[ __ ] stunt uh there's another really
good stunt with like they where they
flipped a car and like the car like went
he it got some air i mean it was way the
[ __ ] up there and like flipped the [ __ ]
over and there was actually a stuntman
in that in there
um
they didn't die but i think they were
wounded pretty badly
uh for for that
and uh yeah so but yeah the stunts in
this are pretty fantastic
uh i really liked the score for this too
and i think you also pointed out that
you like and because it's uh it's stuart
copeland from the police
did the score for this and um it stood
out to me as like
being really good um who else was in
this like the guy that played his
partner
i'm pretty sure who gets killed um but
i'm pretty sure that that guy was the
same guy that played bubba in forrest
gump if i'm not mistaken yeah it might
have been um yeah because i was like it
was bugging me the whole time i'm like
god he's so familiar and then i'm
thinking oh i think that's bubba now the
woman that plays the
psychic
is
tracy griffith who i think is melanie
griffith's sister because the whole time
i was like looking at her i'm like she
looks like really familiar but not quite
and if you see her like you'll know what
i'm talking about like oh well obviously
it looks like melanie griffith but it's
not melanie griffith so there's that you
know what's weird about this too
so i was looking um
you know researching the movie and
everything this was directed by a game
of robert reznikoff
now this is apparently the only movie he
ever directed the only other thing he
worked on i think he did a couple short
films he wrote
that horrible comedy collision course
was it horrible i kind of remember it
was horrible but i don't remember that
much about it with jay leno and pat
morita
he wrote that i don't think he directed
it and he directed this and then he
essentially like disappeared like not in
a you know unsolved mysteries kind of
way but i think he just like [ __ ] off
to to europe like to prague or something
and
i heard that he [ __ ] off to prague
and started writing books about like
weird esoteric religious and occult
practices i don't know if that's true or
not but that's what i heard so this is
like the only movie he ever directed
which i thought was kind of strange i
don't know maybe it just wasn't that
good in experience this is it's i don't
know it's like like you said there were
a lot of other movies that were kind of
similar to this that came out around
this time period like late 80s to early
90s
um i probably up until 1996 when scream
came out and everything started going
like back in a meta slasher type of
direction but i feel like during the
late 80s and early 90s there were a lot
of these
serious like like i said like police
procedural
serial killer movies but with a
religious or an occult element to them
um you know it's almost kind of like it
was a little mini thing and this
this was actually like i said better
than i remembered i didn't
love some things about it i thought the
pacing was a little
odd
um
and i didn't think that uh tracy
griffith who played tess the psychic
i didn't think she was all that great
you know what i mean she seemed a little
awkward or a little not you know maybe
that's just me
but everybody else in it was pretty good
and honestly i really liked
a lot of the
kind of setups like i really like when
one of the cops gets killed and the
serial killer who is supernatural at
this point like leaves him
not really crucified but kind of like
hanging up like on this bridge overpass
like a or underpass and it's like way
way the [ __ ] up in the air and there's
like how the [ __ ] did he get him up
there like they can't figure it out so
i don't know it's just there was just
something like really cool about it now
apparently i don't know
um
a lot about this but apparently this had
a different ending i don't know what the
ending was originally because i don't
think
it survived and apparently lou diamond
phillips i think has done an interview
about this where he's like i don't even
remember what the original uh you know
ending was like but i guess the original
ending they thought it was a little mess
so they re-shot it so now it has that
thing where
they bust open the thing in the
whatever the uh the tunnels and all the
water comes through there and it's like
a big [ __ ] water slide where they're
all kind of like all sliding through
there and [ __ ] and um you know so
so there's that and then i forgot
there's like a nun in this too right
yeah i forgot she's only at the like
very beginning she's the only she comes
to the cardinals bishop to whoever the
hell and she's like uh satan's like
farting around and doing some [ __ ] and
you guys should do something about it
and they're just like no they don't
believe it go back to your uh
they don't believe go back to your uh
what do they call it where the non-slip
convent i almost said coven i don't know
why
i'm getting brain damage
i'm like i keep using like the wrong
[ __ ] word for [ __ ] it started with
the same letter but you know what i'm
saying
but uh yeah some people say oh um
josie says split second with rudger
wrecker hauer is another good one i've
been wanting to actually do that one for
a while because i think that's on 2b as
well and i remember really liking that
movie
um and i you know i like rickerhauer a
lot
and zach said that uh lou diamond
phillips was really hot
so
yeah he i kind of feel like he had a
moment
as like a heartthrob yeah because i
think like in the late 80s
particularly right around the time like
la bamba came out when did la bamba come
out 86.
um he wasn't quite rat pack but
close yeah he was like yeah he's like
like yeah brat pack right yeah he was
like yeah that was like rob lowe and
molly ringwald and amelia estevez he was
like a little bit after ali sheedy a
little bit yeah i kind of feel like he
was just kind of on the outside yeah
with him and kiefer sutherland yeah
all that kind of stuff and like [ __ ]
uh dude to god [ __ ] all
[ __ ] tiger blood what was his name
charlie charlie sheen he's like that
now i'm trying to think i when i think
of brat pack i usually think of
everybody that was in saint alma's fire
right
and and the people that were like in the
john hughes movies
to an extent
but then there were like like you said
there were these other ones that were
like around the periphery right uh like
charlie sheen and stuff like that that
weren't i don't think they were
necessarily part of the brat pack but it
was kind of like i do think i remember
seeing like teen magazines like teen
girl magazines yeah in the late 80s or
that had lou diamond phillips like on
the copper i think if i'm remembering he
was mexican
uh i thought he was filipino but i could
be wrong about that uh somebody should
probably look that up i thought he was
filipino but i might be totally talking
about out of my ass yeah as sometimes i
do
yeah stardog78 uh
also said fallen yeah because yeah i
kind of feel like
the one guy i was watching that reviewed
this movie he seemed like very uh
inordinately inordinate
inordinately upset that fallen with
denzel washington had essentially like
ripped off this movie
um you know many years later because
like i said that was eight years later
and i kept you know i can't really say i
haven't seen fallen in a long time i saw
it in the theater when it came out and i
don't think i've seen it since then but
from what i could remember it's pretty
similar
it's pretty similar the plot to this
it's you know it's it's a
it's essentially like a satanic serial
killer that can jump from body to body
like possess people zack says also the
third exorcist movie sort of
yeah and uh
also and i haven't seen this for a long
time either but
didn't um
house three
also kind of have a similar kind of
thing with a serial killer that could
possess people or jump from bodybuilding
or something i consider i don't know it
feels like there was kind of a lot
i don't know they come up with there was
a lot of those possession was easy to do
back then didn't require as much [ __ ]
special effects so that was uh yeah
that's true because all you had to do
was like contort your face and talk in
like a little bit of a different person
put some makeup on
you know
i kind of well it's weird because i feel
like a few years back
um
it almost kind of like there was another
like a resurgence of like possession
movies you know yeah there was a bunch
of those um and then murder hornet
returns the believers was like serpent
and the rainbow yeah i like serpent and
rainbow better
but uh the believers was good too we
talked about that a little while back
zach says my favorite ken russell movie
is women in love you guys should review
it sometime that's the one with oliver
reed naked wrestling right i'm pretty
sure
that's funny i saw it a long time ago i
remember liking it slasher friend says
there was a 90s b movie horror horror
movie called bats yeah i remember that
with blue diamond phillips that might be
on 2b as well i have to like check that
out and i think like i was watching
something else about this earlier and
somebody said yeah they'd seen an
interview with him like talking about
bats as well so he's like pretty good
natured yeah his mother's filipina
his dad is scotch irish and cherokee man
how did i cut pat
pull that out of my butt i'm not really
sure
i must have heard somebody say that at
some point and it just stuck for
whatever reason
um
let's see three
strong 78 says three name people are
always serial killers or snipers it does
kind of seem like that doesn't it
charles lee ray
got all kinds of ones um tom needs to
get some devil horn implants in his
forehead no i'm good
[Laughter]
you could get fake one i'm good
john gore says finally got to see fx the
other day god that's another one i
haven't seen in a long time i wonder if
you could see that one again there's so
many movies that i saw back in the day
like on cable or in the theater and i
was kind of like man i should watch that
one again but that i forget about it
but then and i'd kind of forgotten about
this one i thought of it when we were
watching the believers but then i forgot
about it again but then when i was
scrolling through 2b last night i was
like oh hey it's the first power let's
[ __ ] watch it um yeah death penalty
like shocker yeah that's another one i
probably
i feel like i watched shocker
five or six years ago i feel like it was
like on the el rey network or some [ __ ]
like that and i was like flipping
through and i was like oh it's that wes
craven movie i haven't seen that in a
long time and
i remember it being like kind of cheesy
and over the top whereas this one
is a lot more serious like it takes
itself a lot more seriously even though
like i said toward the end like some
kind of outlandish [ __ ] happens like
with the seat like the ceiling fan
blender situation and the flying bag
lady and stuff so
but it still takes itself pretty
seriously you know it's not like i felt
like shocker was maybe more
campy
but i haven't seen it in a while so i
don't remember
uh serial killer from beyond the grave
my favorite trope yeah
um
yeah what was that guy who was thinking
time is on my side on the way to the
electric chair yeah that was um
i could that was from fallen right
because i kind of feel like what wasn't
he like singing
that song and that's how you knew that
that person was possessed they started
singing
that rolling stone song
um danny rowling says another underrated
lou diamond phillips film would have to
be the made for tv horror film
route 666
also dale midkiff uh he was in uh pet
cemetery the original pet senator and
laurie petty
i don't think i ever saw that did i
huh well that's another one that i'll
have to like investigate
uh zack says for some reason i want to
see this movie but the psychic is miss
cleo
[Laughter]
did she die
why did it why did i just think of that
i mis is miss cleo still alive does
anybody know
do you guys remember do you remember
miss cleo no she was a
she might still be alive i don't know i
just i for some reason i thought
remembered somebody telling me that she
died
but
she was one of those tv psychics
and she had infomercials like out the
wazoo like all the time like on cable
back in the old days
and she had like a really thick jamaican
accent and i'm not even really sure if
it was a real jamaican accent i don't
really want to say that it wasn't
because i'm not entirely sure
but there was a lot of like scuttlebutt
going around that that that she actually
didn't have a jamaican accent but i do
remember miss cleo though she was kind
of like all over the place
uh
yeah that's it also knock around guys uh
yeah so a lot of people are seeing some
like blue diamond fillers he's actually
like in a lot more movies than i
remembered him in i remembered his
earlier ones i really liked la bamba and
i really liked young guns but i couldn't
really and i remember bats but i didn't
really remember a lot of other ones
um
[Music]
yeah sheila anne says last thing i saw
lou diamond in that in that i liked was
the tv show wolf lake so he is still
like around is he still like
acting he can't be that old i mean he's
not that much older than we are
yeah he is
he's good 15 years older than us you
think yeah you got to be hmm
uh john gore said i saw the stage play
of the king and i with him in it just
remembered
huh okay
yeah and then we were talking about the
brat pack the quarries were just outside
the brat pack a little too young yeah i
kind of when i feel like you know brat
pack i kind of feel like
st almost fire meets the breakfast club
like those people that were in that
that's who i think of he's about 10
years old now she's 60. okay so
yeah
oh and then john goris points out jason
goes to hell jason was a body jumper i
had forgotten all about that aspect of
that
and i just saw that not too long ago so
i really don't have any excuse but yeah
he could jump into other bodies
yeah miss cleo died in 2016. how the
[ __ ] did i remember that i don't know
i remember somebody saying that
so there was that whole thing too but
yeah so
if you i mean if you like satanic serial
killers from the late 80s early 90s uh
if you want to see the movie that denzel
washington's fallen sort of ripped off
you know
uh then watch this movie because it's
it's not bad like i said i think my
favorite thing about it was
the stunts
because i mean this has like way better
stunts than it had any right to have
um particularly like all the jumps off
the building and everything
and some of the car flips and all that
kind of stuff
but yeah it's like you know that's a
pretty good flick if you're into that
kind of stuff better than i remembered
it was that's for sure
so do you have anything else you would
like to add nope
mr tom cocknock or ross
you gave me two middle names
no it's all one word okay it's all one
word
i can think of a better one if you want
that was just all i thought of this
[ __ ] called me a cocknut
that's how she did that's how she's
doing good
well i mean buy it but that's how she
does my middle day might as well be
[ __ ] because that's
[Laughter]
it needs to have like a bunch of
syllables
you know what i mean like lou diamond
phillips that sounds really cool
it sounds like a wrestler that's made up
[Laughter]
you made that up well the thing about it
though is that like a lot of actors make
their name up yeah well because you have
to think like lou phillips isn't a real
original name and there might have
already oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
crushing the game oh god no i'm [ __ ]
redneck today quit making like all these
[ __ ] noises he's giving me like ptsd
with all these [ __ ] sudden noises
that's how you shock a woman just crush
a can and it ends a woman's [ __ ] cold
career
ptsd well i didn't know what you were
doing i was just kind of like i thought
you broke the chair no i'm good that's
what i thought you did i'm good because
i didn't even know you had the can over
there now i just forgot what i was
saying because you keep uh
what well people's names it wasn't
important it's about people's names i
can just make all this noise and make
you stop talking because no one's paying
attention to me do you guys remember
what she was talking about it's about
it's about the no it's about names oh i
said lou phillips was either like it's
not that distinctive a name or there
might have already been somebody in the
screen actors guild that had registered
that name right so you just have to like
add something else to it and maybe
diamond was like a relative's last name
or some [ __ ] like that i don't know so
and he just said oh well i'll just add
that it makes it more distinctive and
you still remember it don't you so it
worked so
qed
that's all i gotta say all right so i
guess we'll
wrap it up we're getting kind of
rambunctious up in here
uh you know it's sunday we're gonna have
a good time
and uh i don't know what we're gonna
watch tonight we'll find something
and then we'll
talk about that tomorrow
so have a good rest of your weekend you
guys and we will see you guys again
tomorrow afternoon